we put the blue boxes around these
because these are the results we're
going to use we're gonna take advantage
off to have a look a bit okay now you
don't need to write this bit down but
can you see that here the idea is that
these two numbers are the same you can
supply any angle you like in there right
any angle you like for instance you find
up to the size of the angle here then in
order to keep the angle of the same size
I would have to double the angle on the
top that makes sense doesn't it be going
to behave in the same way so when I take
the limit it's still going to approach
one okay and you get this guy right but
they're not the same and not they're not
5 X + 5 X + 3 X + 3 X okay but that's
okay just like we've been doing with
integration you're like I want a certain
number at the front because I'm supposed
to have that number there from
differentiating and what what are these
numbers to change their you tell me
which do you think is easier to muck
around with this number or this number
and I'm going to say the denominator
right like gross we're gonna have to do
with identities if you want to change
that so I don't want to do that so I'll
change this guy I want you to be a 5x so
I'm going to say well
do you agree but 3x is 3/5 of 5x
give me that like it's smaller right
it's three points so now this 3/5 it's
just a constant coefficient it is on the
denominator so when I pull it out it's
going to turn upside down right so it's
a constant so I'm just going to pull it
out front so it's PI thirds of that
limit and now hey presto our angles they
match
so I've got my sine-theta on feed around
it just happens that my figure is 5x now
I have foolishly not like myself to have
space so what would my next lightly well
it's five thirds times that please like
I mentioned before like I'm actually kid
right it's not five thirds and then I
ignored asleep
it's five thirds times something maybe
5/3 times so I'm gonna write that down
and there
anything you do will have to account for
this number changing in some way and if
you feel that it makes more sense to you
to put this down right in front and
adjust that one then you go for it just
like with the integration what's
important is you get the right number
there and have it actually changed all
right have a look at this one again same
kind of thing these numbers these angles
they don't match so which do you think
will be easier to muck around with the
numerator completely right so I want
that to be a half a
do you agree that 2h is having a lots of
havoc it's sold right full lots of hot h
right now it's an important step pull
that out so you can demonstrate ah now I
will have feeder and 10-meter it's just
that my theta happens to be pop H did
you have a question
Oh
hold on sorry you're talking about me
just a little
what else
oh you mean right wait isn't that what I
did
what are you lost me I am
I'll let you experiment to show just
quickly that's four times one again
don't skip that step in evaluating
minute that's four okay now I should
clarify my five young soived eliminated
at this one two lost because I kept say
to you like Oh which one is easiest to
muck around with and clearly when it's
just you know turn it by itself without
any trig in it that's the easy target
but here you have no easy targets
so I'm gonna need to separate these
things out you will notice have a look
at my limits right the missing piece is
that I have no feed up by itself
I've sign or something there's a sign
I've got 10 or something but there's no
figure in the numerator or the phenomena
so that's okay I just introduce one okay
now I want I've got the same three
Theatre on the top so I'll leave him on
the top and he needs to be paired with
an angle of sometimes do you agree with
that boy I'm gonna make it the right
angle in a second nobody gets that a bit
since I've divided by theta
I've been up multiply through by theta
as well so that there's no net change
does that make sense so now my side is
paired with a theta and my tan is
pay-per-view tada there's the limits I
was off done and I didn't really need to
do some numerical shuffling in order to
get it to me what I want right for
example if I put a 3 here then I'm going
to need to put a 3 out here does that
make sense
because this is divided by 3 so that's
one support my tray bounced out and then
if I put a 5 here I had better to divide
by 5 so that these balance you see it's
all about just making sure you it's just
like integration it you're balancing
back and forth to make sure you have no
net change so this is 3/5 times 1 times
1 there are two limits there in
operations and then booth evaluate
soup one which gives me an answer